Travis has a question for us hi my name
is Travis and I'm from Adelaide in South
Australia I don't have a whole lot of
things and sometimes I feel like I get a
lot of negativity about that also I get
a lot of negativity about selling
donating or throwing things away
particularly gifts noting that the
people that give me things know I don't
like things I don't talk about
minimalism or push my beliefs on anyone
else I've never been able to figure out
why the hate I'd like to get your views
on this thanks this often comes up when
we make a gigantic change in our lives
or sometimes even a small change that
people are they feel threatened by right
the Judgment Creeps in but of course
judgment is a mirror that reflects the
insecurities of the judge quite often
and so when I get the hate as Travis
talks about that often tells me much
more about the person who's doing out
the hate than it says about my own
personal circumstance
that's right I I think it's important to
note with things like this that there is
no alternative that you can choose
that's going to change the experience of
other people forming negative thoughts
about you if people are giving you a
hard time for not owning much oh you'll
just attract a new set of people who
will give you a hard time for owning a
lot of things if people hate you for
wearing blue well change to red and
they'll hate you for that it might be a
different set of people but this world
is full of people who find all sorts of
superficial reasons to hate others for
all sorts of petty things you're never
going to get rid of that it's about
learning to live with that the second
thing I'll say is that you don't have to
have a psychological theory for why
other people are the way they are in
order to learn how to effectively
establish boundaries that protect you
from The Unwanted consequences of
engaging them I don't think there's any
problem with forming psychological
theories I don't think there's any
problem problem with seeking to
understand why people do the things they
do but you neither have time or you
don't have a requirement to do that for
every situation sometimes it's
sufficient to just know how to stand up
for yourself to just know how to say no
to just know how to say I'm not going to
tolerate that to know how to walk in a
different direction to know how to end a
conversation there are million reasons
for why people do all sorts of things
that are difficult to understand and
there's a time for you to make yourself
a student of psychology and to try to
figure out why people are like that but
there's also a time to just say hey look
I have to go I have to end this
conversation hey look I don't want to
hear it or hey look this is my life I
need you to respect it I don't criticize
you for the number of possessions that
you own I need you to respect the life
that I choose to live can we do that you
know what I mean uh so there's a time
for just setting boundaries and the
reason I say that is because if you've
got a lot of people in your life
hating you you don't want to end up
becoming so preoccupied with them that
you don't give yourself the freedom to
move on until you fully understand them
it may be the case that they're so
radically different from you that you'll
never get to a point of understanding
them and love and respect is about how
you can engage another human being even
when you don't understand them I never
want my ability to love people and
respect them to be dependent on me
seeing life from their point of you I
strive to be that kind of person but you
know what I'm limited too I'm finite too
I've got weaknesses too and sometimes I
come across people where I just don't
know how to put myself in their shoes
but guess what I can love you anyway I
can respect you anyway and I can
establish the kind of context that's
necessary for us to interact with one
another harmoniously I love that because
well there are five words that change
the way that I approach my relationships
would you be willing
to
ellipses if I'm Travis in his scenario
I'm not going to convince anyone which
by the way that was my default my ego is
like you know what I just say the right
things then I will convince this person
that I myself am righteous and what I'm
doing is the appropriate thing to do and
now I need to convince them that
decluttering isn't just good for me it
is good for everyone and this is how you
should live and that's when it turns
into some sort of oppressive Dogma that
isn't useful for our interpersonal
relationships however if I deploy those
five words would you be willing to
respect my decision to declutter if
they're your friend what are they going
to say no screw you I'm not willing to
respect your decluttering of course
there are some things that we don't want
to tolerate if I find out that TK is
doing something illegal and he's a good
friend of mine or he's doing something
immoral or unethical I don't want to
tolerate that but if he's doing
something that's just outside of my
preferences then yes of course I want to
respect that in fact I want to get
curious about it I want to understand
what's going on behind that now of
course it's not your job Travis to make
other people curious about what you're
doing however what I personally found
was as I started simplifying one of the
first things I got was judgment and it
wasn't even mountains of judgment but it
any Judgment at first when you're
embarking on this new thing you can't
really defend it very well you're not
really sure if it's going to work out
for you long term so any level of
scrutiny feels overwhelming oh did I
make the wrong decision oh is this what
I'm supposed to be doing with my life
maybe I made a wrong turn and this is
actually not for me maybe I'm not a
minimalist maybe I'm a
fraud and that impostor syndrome yeah
really just means I'm afraid that I am
not
enough and when I think of that the
truth is I know I'm enough but the tools
that I use will help me get down to the
essence of me and that's what minimalism
has done and minimalism is just one of
many tools but as we encounter those
people who are bringing those negative
feelings the criticisms the caval into
our life sometimes it's just showing me
what their insecurities are and as soon
as I see that I don't need to change
them I want to love them I want to see
them for who they are and recognize that
oh yeah their criticism of me has to do
with the Deep hurt that's going on
inside them that's exactly right man I I
think there are two ways that we can
think about confrontation we can think
of Confrontation as combat but we can
also think of Confrontation as curiosity
confrontation as combat is when I
address an issue by saying something
really assertive and possibly
threatening like hey you need to stop
you need to get out of here I'm not
going to take that anymore and there is
indeed a time and place for
confrontation
by combat however confrontation by
curiosity is when you call something to
attention shining a light on it by
asking an honest but serious question
about it hey man every time you come to
my
home you criticize me for the amount of
things I own and it makes me feel like
you don't respect my choices is that
true now at that moment the other person
might
say
uh yeah man I I guess it is true I I
guess I don't respect your choices
because they they make me concerned in
this way and now you have a conversation
that maybe you need to have with this
friend with this person that you love
who truly doesn't respect your values or
what might occur is they might say oh
I'm sorry I didn't know I was making you
feel that way one of the most
self-defeating fallacies is what I call
the I shouldn't have to fallacy there's
some truth some value that's so obvious
to us because of the way we think the
way we were raised the way we have lived
and when we see others lacking it we
refuse to call it out or have a
conversation about it because of the
belief I shouldn't have to I shouldn't
have to teach another person how to be
more loving I shouldn't have to teach a
person how to show me respect I
shouldn't have to teach a person to not
tease someone uh over something like
that well you can approach it that way
or you can say we're all different we
all come from different backgrounds we
all know different things and you know
what some of us make it all the way up
to 50 60 70 without learning things that
maybe you figured out by the time you
were 15 but maybe we don't live in the
universe that we should ideally live in
maybe we do but I know that we live in
the universe that we actually have and
in the one that we actually have it
happens to be a place where we benefit
from learning from one another and
engaging one another with a spirit of
Charity maybe the people that are
teasing you or giving you a hard time
maybe they don't know that they're
having the impact on you that they're
really having and if you can confront it
with a little curiosity you'll give them
the opportunity to either own what
they're saying or an opportunity to look
at it honestly and then choose to disown
it either way your relationship with
them benefits what you're telling me
right now is as you're taking an
inventory of your stuff in a way way it
allows you to take an inventory of these
other areas of your life yeah in a way
you're taking an inventory of these
relationships and you're realizing like
maybe these relationships have been
judgmental all along but now it's hit
this Source spot you know when you use a
foam roller and all of a sudden you hit
one of those trigger points and it's
like whoa ah
ah man it hit the sore spot it doesn't
mean that you weren't hitting other
spots on the way but like it wasn't a
big deal you didn't experience the pain
but now that you're experiencing the
pain the pain associated with your
material possessions the pain associated
with health or the pain associated with
your home or the pain associated with
your relationships or pain associated
with
boredom you're taking inventory of those
things and saying you know what this is
causing me pain not let me get rid of
the pain but let me investigate the pain
thanks for watching this highlight if
you like to to check out another one you
can watch this clip here or if you like
to watch the full episode for this
highlight clip you can check out this
one here or you can dive into the full
private podcast by subscribing via the
patreon link in the description for this
video your patreon support is what helps
keep this podcast 100% advertisement
free